(slow resonant music)
- The weather's really in
your face in New Orleans.
It is a character in
the play of New Orleans.
This instrument, the weather warlock,
is an audio mirror of
the sunrise and sunset,
so, theoretically, a blind person
could experience the sunrise
and sunset through audio,
in real time.
My name is Quintron;
it's not my real name;
it's a given musician's name.
I definitely consider
myself, first and foremost,
to be a musician, but I'm also a builder
and inventor of electronic
musical instruments,
and the device that
we're talking about today
is called the weather warlock,
which is weather-controlled analog synth.
Right now, we're hearing
the sun just start
to activate the UV sensors
on the outdoor sensor unit.
That puttering sound is the sound
of that sensor just
starting to get enough light
to sonically activate it.
It's using the weather to create music.
There's no microphones; there's no,
it's not the sound of rain.
There are two components:
an inside set of brains,
which is the synthesizer part,
and an outdoor set of sensors.
There is a temperature sensor,
which is effecting the speed of the drone,
this drone.
There is a set of wind
speed controlled sensors,
the faster the wind blows,
the faster they activate
these two notes.
There is a moisture sensor, or rain,
or humidity or snow.
And the last one would be the sky sensor,
which is a sensor at the top,
a little periscope
that's aiming at the sky.
So you can play it like
an instrument, too,
you can just let it do it's thing,
but I can also, you know,
change the timbre of the drone.
So, sunrise is officially over,
according to the weather warlock.
And everyone else.
(resonant electronic drone)
Check one, two.
Good evening, you are tuned
into weatherfortheblind.org,
broadcasting, as usual, out
of New Orleans, Louisiana.
The weather warlock has
become a live, 24/7,
online musical feed.
Sunrise was at 5:15 this morning,
and sunset happening now, as you can hear,
according to our UV sensors.
This hasn't made me see
a sunset differently.
You can just hear it now.
(soft string music)